yeah were you from DC her Washington
Washington here at Maryland
and how long you been out here since
2014
what brought you out to LA
I got out of prison for Jesus Culture
I'm sorry Dennis Prager did indecent
exposure
yeah so we're the details flurry dick I
was a lot of [ __ ] I was in my own
house and uh somebody suddenly he saw me
to the window and I got a case work
[Applause]
[Music]
is that the only time you do in prison
I'm gonna hand twice for those weren't
the same so you've been in prison for
indecent exposure to several times
yeah what have you done since you go to
LA how about angelic battle without
tanks versus out angels
I'm talking to Martha light okay I speak
a little louder said the Archangel
Michael I've been agile battling against
angels and demons
I mean you said you were working in the
porn industry as well I did I did for a
while
I need a Jesse James or no star the
Saturday sighs old porn I did frog I
didn't never got paid for they were
supposed to pay me but uh now I was in
jail for some bleedin - not that you
know they didn't I lost a number when I
was in jail I'm going to contact them
again and tell me better chocolate I
barely remember my childhood you don't
remember it yeah it was pretty bad my
mom told me that was alright though can
you say your mom was mean with them
she's beating
the exhibits no no not really
no family no because no I play guitar I
play guitar player metal and up I do the
Hard Rock Air Medal
I'll sing I'm sorry I'll sing using yep
I seen out the scorpions
yeah
what with white dogs here in the street
are you playing on any topic
you stay away from the drug yeah
where do you sleep we're there on the
street not in the shelter oh you're the
job yeah okay
I'll read the Bible a lot sir need to
bottle lock you read the Bible on the
out and lodging boarding English and
buddies out coming back
probably what you get for part of doing
the Psalms softer good write a song
that's where all the power comes from
those are the power that oldie goes like
evangelizing himself about the Holy
Ghost and everything like that
in public this is why you're supposed to
so I something I do
Bielski out everything tell me about the
attack - yeah it's an interesting
tattoos yes this is a seal of God right
here like in the Book of Revelations
this is a Tsar David the cross sign
Jesus trying to site you find the back
of cars yeah I see it
girls girls girls girls
everybody girls girls girls back to
other faiths yeah my phone as well how
many is that rock and roll man is about
robbing right here there's an AoE this
dollar sign and I'm here chest and back
you know what you call the largest
scorpion tattoo the growth no in
Oklahoma I know fun with that it had oh
that I got tattooed in prison it's out
I'm a Scorpio I'm a Scorpio I out born
October 30 it's 1979 date of the Dead
the red warrior spends apocalypse yeah
it's quite a - you go all right that's
about all my tattoos oh that's cool
Jesse thank you for talking make sure
your story I think our logic up yours